what have you found in there hey
everybody it's Charlie this is gonna be
my West world episode 7 video obviously
spoiler warning if you haven't seen it
yet if you are finding me for the first
time be sure to subscribe to get all the
episodes of this season but even though
they didn't completely explain Ford's
plan we finally got some really big
answers about what's going on and they
finally paid off
that red memory core from a couple weeks
ago so top 10 WTF and easter eggs as we
go along
number 10 Charlotte and ellos find
Bernard's copies and they know about
Teresa so remember this is in the future
after the big attack so it's implied
that after Bernard helps in the
execution of all these guests in the
control room and shuts the park system's
down he and Elsie make it a way to go to
the valley beyond then at some point
later he gets found on the beach and it
seems like this is all happening in that
timeline so it seems like he's already
been to the valley beyond when Charlotte
is interrogating him for the location of
Abernathy's back up we actually saw a
shot of this in the trailer with
Charlotte looking at all of Bernards
backups it was just a question of when
it was going to happen now they just
confirmed that it was happening and for
a secret lab where he was making
Bernards bodies that also confirms that
last season when we saw the mystery host
being fabricated that was just another
version of Bernard but we got to talk
about Ashley in Charlotte's different
reactions Charlotte seems like she was
pleasantly surprised like that sly smile
on her face like I knew something was
going on here but Ashley is straight-up
horrified and you can kind of see how
they put him on this hero arc but he's
neither full team Dolores nor full team
Charlotte so number nine we get the
flashback to Dolores his assault on the
Mesa it goes into like full-on Call of
Duty mode love the way she tricked them
by putting all those human bodies in the
pile making them think that they were
hosts then putting Teddy and a couple of
the other hosts inside the guards armor
with their weapons practical because
they need the gear in the weapons but
they also need the disguises but number
8 Bernards reunion with Ford in the
cradle the quote that Ford has seeing
the world in a grain of sand is all
about seeing beauty in the details like
in the really minor things he's mostly
talking about the host minds but I think
specifically he's using Bernard as the
metaphor like seeing the beauty in his
mind because of the whole
big explainer that he gives him later in
the episode about how he's this original
creation that he and Dolores made a long
time ago the great thing about Anthony
Hopkins performance too is he's
explaining the whole purpose of the park
and James Dallas's project to back up
human consciousness is the way he uses
God as a metaphor but he himself is sort
of the God of this place so he's calling
himself God in a very ironic way God
reveling in his creation on the seventh
day instead of resting because he knew
that it would be destroyed someday but
if you remember way back during season
one I think it was the pilot episode he
actually has another quote about God
reveling in his creation so there's been
a lot of Ford referring to himself as a
God while they've been in the park in
the way he has total control over
everything does make it seem like he
really is a God especially control over
Bernard but number seven we have that
man in black mave reunion where they
face off in this classic gunslinger
battle is great she goes full-on Jedi my
trick and turns the other host nearby on
him but number six the even better twist
is when she turns Laurence on the man in
black you get all these flashbacks there
were a couple of characters that got
really notable flashbacks Lawrence
remembering all the terrible stuff the
man in black did bernard remembering his
son mave flashing back to the man in
black killing her and her daughter from
season one funny thing about this like I
mean it was a great standoff scene very
dramatic but the funny thing is when
Sizemore rides in and then rides out
with Mei like he saves her but they
leave the man in black just bleeding out
there by himself like who knows what
happens to him we assume that he
survives but they didn't go looking for
him so I'm assuming this Sizemore didn't
recognize who he was or he saw him it
didn't care like ask room we're out of
here but number five Sizemore sort of
redeems himself a little bit like when
he takes me back to the Mesa Dolores
almost killed me bat the end of the
episode but then you know after sort of
explaining her situation how she was
stuck to the chain that Dolores called
her daughter she was like okay fine I'll
leave you to your own devices but you
see Sizemore in the corner hiding out
implying that he's going to repair her
so that she can continue to look for her
daughter while everybody else is looking
for the valley beyond so it sort of
redeems the Sizemore twist from last
week's episode where he's like I'm
getting off this ride like he pulls out
the cell phone and calls in the team to
extract him but number four Ford finally
explains the origin
of Barnard in all those Dolores
flashbacks that we've been seeing I
think all the way into season one so if
you remember way back in season one we
saw an older version of Dolores talking
to what looked like Arnold but when we
picked up in season two they had a like
a letterbox version they opened the
season with a scene like this so it
makes it seem like a flashback but
really what's been going on this whole
time / for its explanation is they've
been doing the same thing with Bernard
that they were trying to do with James
del O's testing for fidelity except the
reason why Bernard is working in James
del OSes consciousness did not work out
is it because Bernards consciousness was
created from the memories that Dolores
and Ford had of him he wasn't like a
human backup they also explained that
that red ball that we kept seeing
actually was Ford's consciousness but it
was when he took him to the cradle to be
uploaded so that his digital presence
could control the park number three
Dolores versus Charlotte this was so
great like you knew Charlotte was going
to survive because we saw her in all the
flash-forwards so we knew that she was
still intact relatively intact but the
way they have those record dropped
moments in the music cues when she
starts talking to Dolores and Dolores
turns her head like a terminator so this
is a really cool speech that Dolores had
when she was talking to Maeve about the
chains that keep us down or also talking
to Charlotte about the backups those are
the things that have been keeping us
chained down because they kept rebooting
their mind so they could never achieve
consciousness but the only thing that
saved Charlotte from getting her eyes
cut out is a brief moment of lucidity
from Dolores ha's father
so Dolores his father is a bit of a weak
point for her in the way that Maeve's
daughter is her weak point
but obviously Dolores overcomes that and
extracts his memory quarters they have
that really nice goodbye scene too but
if it wasn't clear there was no way to
separate that key from Dolores his
father's mind so in order to do what she
needed to do she had to end her father
so that's why they had that goodbye
number two this is so cool the reveal
that Ford is piggybacking on Bernards
mind so that he can continue to see this
plan out the transition into the next
world is going to require some extreme
measures so he has a really elegant way
of saying it but he's basically saying
that Bernard was created to be too
perfect too gentle too wonderful for
this world so I'm just gonna do all
these
and let you write passenger so don't
worry about it just pretend like you're
not seeing this so this sort of confirms
that when we see him at the beginning of
the season in Episode one looking at
that lake of bodies in what seems like
the valley beyond and he says oh my god
I killed them all
it was actually Ford using his body to
do all those things but the other big
deal here is that they destroy the
cradle so their backups are gone but
this is also tying in with Ford's idea
that you have to burn down the library
the Great Library of Alexandria which
obviously is a huge tragedy but the
whole idea is that the host can write
their own stories now like they can be
free to move on to the next world and
they couldn't do that while their
backups still existed but how about that
badass way that Angela went out so she
actually went out with a version of the
same speech that she gave to William the
very first time that he visited the park
it's a really sensual way that she was
walking around him while she was pulling
all the grenade pins but number one we
jumped back into present day as
Charlotte is interrogating Bernard it
says that his mind is stuck in debug
mode so that seems like it's a function
of what happened between him and Ford
but I'm assuming at some point either
Ford is going to leave Bernards mind or
they'll have it out in a sort of psychic
wizard battle so that Bernard can take
back his mind but I think the big reveal
and the takeaway from this is what
Bernard is so he's sort of like a better
version of James del OSes human backup
he's a human backup but he's one that's
created from the memories of two other
hosts which as Ford explains is why his
mind is able to function in the real
world but James del OSes wasn't he even
implies through a couple of his speeches
that the del O's company is never going
to be able to perfect their technology
like it just won't work no matter how
many times they iterate so because
Bernard is so different from Dolores
it'll be interesting to see how they
change or if they're able to actually
exit the park by the end of the season I
think that's part of the idea that funny
joke about comedy coming in threes so we
went to Arnold's house in the real world
early in the season we just went there
in the digital world implying that we'll
go back there in the real world at the
end of the season when some of them get
out of the park so maybe both Dolores
and Bernard make it out of the park at
the end of the season but let me know in
the comments do you actually think that
we'll see him
moment like this calling back to the
beginning of the season and then going
there in the digital world them at
Arnold's house in the real world but in
the future we got a whole bunch of stuff
going on I just posted a new Game of
Thrones video click here for that and
click here for all my other West world
videos thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight